.
NOW, GREG GUTFELD.
[APPLAUSE]
>> SO TALK ABOUT ROUGH WEEK.
TERRORIST ATTACK AT THE KABUL
AIRPORT KILLING 13 U.S. SERVICE
MEMBERS.
10 MARINES, TWO ARMY SOLDIERS
AND ONE NAVY CORPS MEN.
AT LEAST 160 AFGHANS WERE
KILLED.
BELIEVED TO HAVE BEEN CARRIED
OUT BY THE ISLAMIC.
SOMEHOW, I DON'T FEEL COM
COMFORTED.
THE PRESIDENT SEEMED DEFEATED,
LOST BETWEEN SPASMS OF ANGER AND
FOLLOWED INSTRUCTIONS TO USE A
LIST OF REPORTERS GIVEN TO HIM
BY WHOEVER IS IN CHARGE.
JEN WAS ACTING AS THOUGH SHE WAS
DOING US A FAVOR INSTEAD OF HER
JOB.
A JOB I WOULDN'T WISH ON MY
WORST ENEMY.
HOW COULD EVERYONE BUT THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE NOT SEE THIS
COMING?
MAYBE THEY WERE SO BUSY
DISTRACTING US THAT THEY GOT
DISTRACTED WHILE DISTRACTING US.
LOOK, I'M A MAGAZINE EDITOR
TURNED CLASS CROWN WITH AN
OBSESSION OVER UNICORNS AND I
COULD SEE THIS COMING.
THE BLIND SHEIK COULD SEE THIS
COMING.
HOW COULD THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE
NOT?
PERHAPS THEY DID AND JUST
ASSUMED CARNAGE IS THE PRICE WE
PAY OR MAYBE THEY JUST
UNDERESTIMATED THE RISK WHICH
BOGGLES THE MIND BUT AGAIN I'M
NO EXPERT.
YET, HOW DO I KNOW BETTER?
GOING FORWARD, HOW CAN WE HAVE
ANY CONFIDENCE IN OUR LEADERS?
I WOULDN'T LET THEM LEAD MY
PAINT BALL TEAM.
THEY MAKE THE BAY OF PIGS LOOK
WELL THOUGHT OUT.
WHO GIVES CONTROL OF THE AIRPORT
PERIMETER AS WELL AS INFO ON
AMERICANS?
COULD WE HAVE MADE IT ANY EASIER
FOR THESE MAGGOTS.
WHEN HAS THE MILITARY WITH THE
BEST WEAPONS NOT HAD A CHOICE.
INSTEAD THEY LED US TO A PLACE
WHERE THERE WAS NO PLAN B.
THAT'S NOT LEADERSHIP.
THAT'S RESIGNATION.
AND WHERE ARE THE RESIGNATIONS?
WHERE ARE THE FIRINGS?
MAYBE GENERAL MILLY SHOULD PUT
DOWN DeANGELO AND PICK UP THE
ART OF WAR.
WE'VE GOT A GOOD VISUAL OF THE
WORD STRANDED AT THE PODIUM
YESTERDAY.
BIDEN IS STRANDED.
WHEN REALLY IT'S ON THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA.
THEY ONLY WANTED JOE TO WIN, BUT
NOT TO GOVERN.
AND NOW HE HAS TO LEAD AND HE
CAN'T.
DON'T EVEN THINK OF IMPEACHMENT.
WHO COULD REPLACE HIM?
IT'S INCREDIBLE HOW THE WOKE
EMBRACE HAS DESTROYED THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
YOU CAN'T LEAD A COUNTRY YOU
THINK IS RACIST WHILE OBSESSING
OVER PRONOUNCE AND CRACK POTS
AND VIKING HATS SO WE RELIED ON
THE TALIBAN TO KEEP US SAFE.
LIKE LETTING MANSON BABY-SIT
YOUR KID.
IT REMIND ME OF THE PORTLAND
MAYOR WHO PLED TO MAKE PEACE
WITH ANTIFA.
WE CHOSE A REGIME THAT STONES
WOMEN TO DEATH THAT SHOWS TOO
MUCH ANKLE AT THE EXPENSE OF OUR
TROOPS.
WHY ARE SO MANY SMART PEOPLE
MAKING BAD DECISIONS.
MAYBE THEY ARE NOT THAT SMART OR
MAYBE POLITICS POLLUTED THEIR
DECISION-MAKING DRIVEN BY A
STILL FRESH LOATHING OF TRUMP OR
OUR COUNTRY ITSELF.
HAVING TO GET OUT BY THE END OF
AUGUST WAS A POLITICAL CHOICE.
A SELF-INDUCED DEADLINE WITH THE
EMPHASIS ON DEAD.
NOT PROVIDING ADEQUATE SECURITY,
ANOTHER POLITICAL CHOICE.
WE COULDN'T HAVE THAT MANY
TROOPS THERE, RIGHT?
THAT'S BAD OPTICS, THEY THOUGHT.
I'VE GOT WORSE OPTICS, A TARGET
WITH MORE SITTING DUCKS THAN A
DECOY FACTORY.
REMEMBER HOW UNDER TRUMP THERE
WAS A NEW CRISIS EVERY DAY,
EVERY HOUR.
CNN TOLD US THE WALLS WERE
CLOSING IN FROM THE STEEL
DOSSIER TO THE TAX RETURNS AND
EVERY PHONY SCANDAL IN BETWEEN.
THOSE SCANDALS WERE THE GOOD OLE
DAYS, HIGH CALORIC OUTRAGE JUNK
FOOD.
COMPARE AND CONTRAST TO NOW,
KABUL IS THE REAL DEAL.
REAL HORROR, REAL SCANDAL.
A BLIND CONSENSUS OF SHEER
INCOMPETENCE.
SO WHAT DO WE DO?
I'M NO MILITARY GENERAL BUT THEN
AGAIN, DOES THAT MATTER?
WE MUST TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
OUR PEOPLE OVER THERE.
GET THEM ALL OUT AND OBLITERATE
THOSE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
BOMBINGS.
AND WHEN WE'RE DONE WE CAN
DECIDE WHAT TO DO WITH JOE AND
THE REST OF THAT CLOWN CAR.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
AFTER COMMITTING 20 YEARS TO ONE
EFFORT WE ACCEPTED THE VERY
OPPOSITE OF THAT EFFORT.
QUICKLY AND WITHOUT LOOKING
BACK.
LIKE A HUSBAND WHO TELLS HIS
WIFE AND KID THAT HE'S GOING OUT
FOR CIGARETTES ONLY TO NEVER
RETURN, LEAVING HIS LOVED ONES
VULNERABLE AND UNPROTECTED.
SOMEONE SHOULD PAY FOR THAT.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME I DON'T WANT
TO HEAR [ BLEEP ] ABOUT JANUARY
6, CLIMATE CHANGE, MASK MANDATES
OR VOTER SUPPRESSION OR WHATEVER
GASSY, STUPID POLITICAL THEATER
YOU'RE TRYING TO PEDAL UNTIL YOU
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET US OUT OF
THIS MESS.
BUT MAYBE ASKING THEM FOR HELP
TO GET US OUT IS AS STUPID AS
RELYING ON THE TALIBAN FOR THE
SAME THING.
[APPLAUSE]
>> WELCOME.
TONIGHT'S GUEST.
HE'S SO WHITE HE THINKS OATMEAL
IS ETHNIC FOODS.
>> HE'S THE SECOND MOST POPULAR
JOE ON THE SHOW.
WRITER COMEDIAN JOE DEVITO.
HE'S THE THIRD MOST POPULAR JOE
ON THE SHOW.
COMEDIAN JOE MACKEY.
>> AND THE FIRST THING SHE DOES
WHEN SHE WAKES US IS THANK THE
GARDENER FOR MOWING AROUND HER.
ALL RIGHT.
HOW DID YOU FEEL AFTER LISTENING
TO BIDEN'S SPEECH?
DID YOU FEEL CONFIDENT IN HIS
ABILITY TO LEAD US?
>> IT WAS SIMILAR TO MOST OF HIS
PRESS CONFERENCES.
COMPLETELY OUT OF IT THAT IMAGE
THAT YOU SHOWED, THE MOST
INTERESTING THING ABOUT THAT
IMAGE IS REALLY, IT'S NOT THE
IMAGE ITSELF, IS THAT HE
COULDN'T ANSWER THE QUESTION.
SO JOE DOES THINGS, WHEN HE
CAN'T ANSWER THE QUESTION,
SOMETIMES HE LAUGHS, ALWAYS
INAPPROPRIATE.
SOMETIMES HE SAYS COME ON, MAN,
BUT THE AMAZING THING, IF YOU
SEARCH THIS ON GOOGLE AND LOOK
AROUND THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA, THE
WAY THEY WROTE ABOUT THAT IMAGE,
I MEAN, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
FORGET THAT IMAGE, HE WAS STUCK,
HE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO,
"WASHINGTON POST" SAID BIDEN
SHOWS FRUSTRATION WITH REPORTER.
OBVIOUSLY AN EMOTIONAL MOMENT.
IT WAS AN EMOTIONAL MOMENT.
HE COULDN'T ANSWER THE QUESTION.
AND THE THING IS, EVEN IF THAT'S
YOUR INTERPRETATION, THAT BIDEN
WAS SHOWING FRUSTRATION WITH A
REPORTER, THAT'S NOT A STORY.
THE STORY IS, HE CAN'T ANSWER
THE QUESTION.
>> GREG: YES.
YES.
NOT GOOD.
JOE, MY DEFENSE WHICH I HAD
THERE BRIEFLY IN THE MONOLOGUE
IS IT REALLY ISN'T JOE'S FAULT
BECAUSE IT WAS THE DEMOCRATS AND
THE MEDIA WHO JUST WANTED --
THOUGHT HE WAS THE BEST CHANCE
TO WIN DESPITE HIS DECLINE IN
FACULTIES.
AND HIS INABILITY TO LEAD.
SO THEY PUT HIM FORWARD AND SAID
WE'LL WORRY ABOUT LEADING LATER.
WE'LL PUT HIM IN THERE SO ISN'T
THIS MORE ON THE DEMOCRATS AND
THE MEDIA WHO PUSHED HIM THERE,
NOT SO MUCH THIS BEFUDDLED SAD
MAN?
>> HE'S DEFINITELY A BEFUDDLED
SAD MAN BUT BEFORE THAT HE WAS A
OBNOXIOUS BLOW HEART FOR ABOUT
40 YEARS.
YES, I HAVE AS MUCH CONFIDENCE
HE'S GOING TO LEAD US OUT OF
THIS THING.
HE COULDN'T LEAD CUOMO TO LADY'S
NIGHT.
THAT'S HOW OUT OF IT HE IS.
HE'S PATHETIC, AND I SEE, THE
AMOUNT OF SPIN THEY ARE TRYING
TO PUT ON THIS, THEY ARE REALLY
LOSING TOUCH WITH REALITY
BECAUSE IF THEY ARE TRYING TO
SAY, WELL, WE HAD TO GET OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN EVENTUALLY, OKAY, I
THINK ALMOST EVERYONE AGREES
WITH THAT.
>> GREG: NO ONE DISAGREES.
>> IN HINDSIGHT WE PROBABLY
COULD HAVE GOTTEN OUT OF THERE
IN 2006 BECAUSE I REALLY THINK
ONLY NATION WE SHOULD DO IS THE
NATION THAT'S LOCATED BETWEEN
MEXICO AND CANADA.
WE DON'T NEED TO MESS WITH THESE
OTHER COUNTRIES BUT THERE IS A
DENIES BETWEEN SAYING YOU'RE ON
A BUS AND WE NEED TO TURN
AROUND.
YOU APPLY THE BRAKE AND PULL
OVER.
YOU DON'T VEER OFF THE ROAD AND
SMASH INTO A BRICK WALL AND SAY,
BUT I STOPPED THE BUS, ISN'T
THAT WHAT YOU WANTED?
WHAT WE'RE SEEING, IT'S NOT A
FAILURE OF OUR TROOPS, I HATE TO
SAY THIS, I DON'T THINK I CAN
BLAME THE TALIBAN.
THEY ARE DOING EXACTLY WHAT THEY
HAVE ALWAYS DONE.
IT'S THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE IN CHARGE OF THIS COUNTRY
AND WHEN OBAMA WAS QUOTED AS
SAYING DON'T UNDERESTIMATE JOE'S
ABILITY TO F THINGS UP, I THINK
WE'RE JUST SEEING THE BEGINNING
OF THAT.
HE USED AN OLD ADAGE, YOU CAN'T
BLAME THE FROG FOR WHAT THE
SPORPION DOES TO THE FROG.
I GOT THAT OFF A CRACKERJACK.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOUR FEELINGS
ARE TOWARD TRUMP GOOD OR BAD,
BUT I'M ASKING YOU TO
HYPOTHESIZE, WOULD HE HAVE DONE
THIS?
>> IT'S A TOUGH QUESTION TO
ANSWER, BUT IT IS WEIRD TO HEAR
JOE BIDEN SAY, I'M STUCK BY THAT
MAY 1 DEADLINE THAT TRUMP
NEGOTIATED TO WITHDRAW, BUT BY
MY CALENDAR IT'S LATE AUGUST.
IT'S ALSO A WEIRD SITUATION TO
ME BECAUSE I GOT FIRED FROM
TELEMARKETING FOR BEING TOO
POLITE.
YET IT SEEMS LIKE THE WASHINGTON
GENERALS HAVE MORE SUCCESS
AGAINST THE HARLEM GLOBETROTTERS
THAN THE GENERALS IN WASHINGTON
HAVE SUCCESS IN ANYTHING.
BUT THEY NEVER SEEM TO LOSE
THEIR JOB, AND IT SEEMS LIKE
WHEN THEY -- THEY CREATE A
DISASTER AND I TURN ON A LOT OF
MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND IT'S THE
SAME PEOPLE THAT WERE INVOLVED
IN CREATING THIS DISASTER.
HOW SHOULD WE GET OUT OF THIS
DISASTER?
IT'S LIKE THERE ARE NO
CONSEQUENCES EVER.
>> GREG: BIDEN WAS PART OF THE
DISASTER FOR EIGHT YEARS AND HE
PRETENDS LIKE HE WAS ALWAYS
AGAINST THIS.
IT'S NOT THAT HARD TO FIND A
TAPE OF HIM TALKING ABOUT NATION
BUILDING.
JUST TYPE IN GOOGLE, JOE BIDEN,
NATION BUILDING.
>> YOU CAN EVEN GO BACK IN MUCH
MORE RECENT HISTORY WHEN HE SAID
THE TALIBAN WOULDN'T TAKE OVER
AND IT WOULDN'T LOOK LIKE
SAIGON.
>> WRONG ON BOTH COUNTS, CAT.
YOU HOST ADD RADIO PROGRAM IN
WHICH ONE OF THE CALLERS WAS
YOUR HUSBAND WHO SPENT TIME IN
AFGHANISTAN.
>> YES.